Mind Your Decisions, Presh Talwalkar here.
Start with a circle. Draw a chord, and then draw another chord that makes a 30 degree angle with this chord, then draw another chord that's 30 degrees apart.
If the chord on the left has a length of 10, and the chord on the right has a length of 12,
what is the length of the chord in the middle whose value is x?
I saw a similar problem on r/HomeworkHelp.
Pause the video if you'd like to give it a try ,and when you're ready, keep watching to learn how to solve this problem
We'll solve this problem by working in steps. First, focus on this part of the diagram.
This is a 30 degree inscribed angle corresponding to this arc of the circle.
If we have another inscribed angle for the same arc, it'll have the same measure by the inscribed angle theorem.
So this inscribed angle will be 30 degrees.
Now we'll do a similar thing for this inscribed angle.
It corresponds to this arc of the circle; therefore,this inscribed angle will also measure 30 degrees.
Now go back to the diagram and focus on this isosceles triangle.
The sides opposite the 30 degree angles will be equal to each other, and let's say each of them has a value of y.
We'll go back to the original diagram, and now we can focus on just this quadrilateral.
We'll break it down into two different triangles.
For the triangle on the right we can use
Al-Kashi's law of cosines to get that y^2 = 12^2 + x^2 - 2(12)x cos 30.
We'll do a similar thing for this triangle,and we get y^2 = 10^2 + x^2 - 2(10)x cos 30.
We now have a system of two equations.
We'll subtract the second equation from the first the y^2 terms will cancel out and x^2 terms will cancel out.
So we're left with 0 = 12^2 - 10^2 and then we have to be careful here. We have -24x cos 30 degrees
minus a negative, so that'll become a positive
20x cos 30 degrees, so that results in -4x cos 30 degrees.
We can now solve this equation. We rearrange the equation and then solve for x and that simplifies to be
22 divided by the square root of 3 and that's our answer. And if we go back to the original diagram,
there's another way that we can write it x = the simple average of 10 and 12
Divided by cos of 30 degrees. In fact, we can generalize this formula!
Suppose we have a valid diagram with chords of a and b, and this angle is equal to Θ.
You can actually prove using the same method in this video that x = 0.5(a+b)/cos Θ (the simple average of a and b)
The middle chord is the simple average, or arithmetic mean, multiplied by an adjustment factor of 1/cos Θ.
It's like we've discovered a new type of average of how cord lengths progress in a circle!
It's not technically new, because someone probably will have discovered it thousands of years ago,
but it was new to me, and that's the joy of discovery in mathematics.
Thanks for making Mind Your Decisions one of the best channels on YouTube. As always,
thanks for watching, and thanks for your support.